what is stopping you from staying from  from working and reach out and cleaning  the house  gender roles  what's stopping you from having the  husband stay home there's nothing  stopping you hey Truckee it's stopping  me  if I if I be willing to come home and  clean the house but patriarchal society  doesn't we are bound to gender roles  we're not though like if I if I because  I'm I'm I'm so if I if I date someone  and I want to work and he I I do well on  YouTube right I could have a house  husband if I want to or  but that's what I'm saying there's  nothing stopping you which is  good but Society doesn't make it easy  not really just my puzzles yes Society  does not make it easy  men are not conditioned to be  people who do unpaid child care and  unpaid housework they're not conditioned